sigue en vilo la situación de novak
djokovic antes que el tribunal del
circuito de australia decida si deporta
al tenista número 1 el lunes los
representantes judiciales de djokovic
argumentaron que obtuvo la exención
médica debido a un contagio por kobe 19
el 16 de diciembre australia exige una
pauta completa de vacunación contra el
cob y 19 o una excepción médica para
ingresar al país djokovic no ha
compartido su información de vacunación
pero ha sido crítico de la misma como
requisito obligatorio lo que despertó el
descontento de los australianos que
durante casi dos años vivieron un
estricto cierre total ante el mundo
melbourne una de sus ciudades más
grandes cuenta con el récord mundial de
confinamiento con más de 262 días
repartidos en seis encierros diferentes
por lo que los ciudadanos exigieron que
se confirmara si su excepción era válida
australia qué estás haciendo
jesús todos el primer ministro y todo
eso que están haciendo qué pasa con
ustedes el mejor jugador del mundo y le
impide jugar para que preocupar
información sobre su salud
él tiene todo el derecho nadie tiene
derecho a tener información privada
sobre la salud de alguien más sin nadie
no ha de aprobarse la deportación al
deportista se le podría prohibir la
entrada a australia hasta por tres años
una semana después de la decisión del
juzgado el 17 de enero empieza el
abierto de australia para el que el
deportista sea preparado
djokovic ha ganado 9 veces el abierto de
australia de individuales masculino
a la tenista a renata voracova también
se le revocó el visado tras problemas
con su extensión y horas después
abandonó el país